une de ces demoiselles mesdemoiselles va
m'aider à mettre nos micros cravates ce
que je n'ai je me suis très bien faire
voilà denise merci on voit pour la
première fois les présentatrices nous
avons banni définitivement les vieux
mots anglo-saxons et mal sonnant jalons
des présentatrices devant deux
ravissantes demoiselles
il faut peut-être de nice commencé par
présenter celle qui n'est pas encore
très connu c'est à dire celle qui nous
arrive de corse et de nice en passant
par nice qui est aux côtés de villes de
clerck christine freesia qui est un bien
joli nom de fleur qui vous va te répète
vous étiez figurines et vous êtes
devenue présentatrice d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien evelyne dhéliat alors
nous la connaissons tous et j'aimerais
bien que de nice nous dise quelle est la
différence entre les speakerines et les
présentatrices qu'est ce qu'il ya de
nouveau en dehors du terme
vous n'êtes plus des potiches qu'on met
sur une cheminée
manifestement vous n'êtes plus de femmes
troncs j'espère que la caméra comment
vous êtes finalement sur la voie de
devenir des journalistes à dire vous
allez faire vos programmes non pas au
programme mais la rédaction de vos
programmes vous même depuis je vous
posais une question annexe qu'est ce que
en dehors de la télévision vous aimez
dans la vie si oui vous vous chacune
séparément on va tous ensemble sinon
vous allez me répondre la belote si je
vous réponds c'est une question
collective mais en dehors la télévision
est ce qu'il ya une chose particulière
c'est la lecture le cinéma le rêve la
nature oui et vous oblige le cinéma et
vos christine la lecture ayhan a un peu
pour tout je voudrais aussi préciser une
chose vos origines aux unes et aux
autres car je crois qu'on ne connaît
bien les gens que lorsque l'on sait de
quel village ils sortent alors votre
village avoue denise c'est un grand
village nice lis vos evelyne oui la
région bordelaise de quel côté du côté
des landes du pt du périgord à bordeaux
bordeaux bordeaux et vous christine
c'est plutôt la corse en revanche
revenant parmi ceux là vous êtes vous
revenu sur le continent comment
s'appelle votre village et vous à flines
l'île de france je crois vous avez des
parents belges chez nous fait très
plaisir parce que nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup de téléspectateurs dans le nord
et nous sommes heureux que la beauté des
filles du nord soit présente sur tf1 ce
soir